Now that we have discussed means and
analysis in problem production, let's
revisit one of the problems that we
would encounter when we were talking
about the Raven's test of intelligence.
So imagine that this is A and this is B.
We can think of this as an initial
state and this as a goal state.
We know that A has been
transformed into B.
Now we can think in terms of
a sequence of operations,
that will transform this initial
state into the goal state.
It is one sequence.
Delete it out,
then move the diamond out of the circle.
Then expanded out.
Let us now see, we can think of this
as an outward or means of analysis
because each move here, brings us
a little closer to the goal state.
The advantage of doing this analysis and
coming up with a sequence of
transformations that will take us from
the initial state of goal state as that.
We cannot in [INAUDIBLE] of applying
the same set of transformations
to the image free, let's do that.
We'll apply one transformation at
a time, so we'll apply delete.
We delete the dot.
Now we apply move to this state, and
it can give rise to several states.
We have shown two here.
Both of these spheres fulfill the
requirements of this move operation of
taking the diamond outside the circle.
And now for each of the states,
we can apply the operation of expand.
Here we are expanding the circle,
here too we are expanding the circle,
although with different amounts.
Once again the question here is,
what in the image A corresponds
to what in image C?
How do we know that
the diamond inside here
corresponds to the circle
inside the triangle here?
We'll discuss this in detail when we
discuss analogical reasoning, but for
now, here is a partial answer.
Remember that we had a semantic
network representation of the image A.
And in that representation, we said
that the diamond is inside the circle.
Now, we also have a semantic
network representation of image C.
And that semantic network representation
says that the circle is inside
the triangle.
But it's that inside
relationship that hints that
this circle must
correspond to the diamond.
Because here the diamond is inside and
here the circle is inside.
So note then, that their presentation
allows us to answer several questions
about similarity, about correspondence
and when we have metals, like means and
analysis then we can do a systematic
analysis of this transformations, and
try to transfer this set of
transformations to the new problem.
>> What's interesting is we can also see
this as an example of problem reduction.
We initially just had a big
problem that we had to solve.
But here,
we've reduced it to three subgoals.
Our first subgoal is to find
the transformation between A and B.
Our second subgoal, is to transfer
that transformation to C and
find some candidate states for D.
And our third subgoal, would be to
compare those candidate states for
D to each of the choices in our problem.
>> That's good analysis, David.
Let's go one step further.
This also has generated.
We are generating solutions that we can
then test against the various choices
that were given to us.
So in this particular problem,
you can see means and analysis working,
problem reduction working,
and the Raven's test working.
Often, solving the complex problem
requires a combination of AI techniques.
At one point,
one might use problem reduction.
At another point, one might use
the Raven's test, and at a third point,
one might use means and analysis.
Notice also, that the one single
knowledge representation of semantic
network supports all three
of these strategies.
The coupling between the knowledge
representation of semantic network, and
any of these three strategies,
problem reduction, means and analysis,
and generating test is weak.
Later on we'll come across
methods in which knowledge and
the problem solving method
are closely coupled.
The knowledge affords
certain inferences, and
inferences demand certain
kinds of knowledge.
This is why these methods
are known as Weak Methods.
Because the coupling between
this universal method and
the knowledge representation is weak.